hey everybody uh just a reminder i got
new tour dates this week oh jesus uh
everything will be on sale tomorrow
friday april 9th
at 10 a.m local time um i guess that's
pacific time my time i don't know what
that means
uh shows are starting to sell fast
evidently in in
the pre-sale so we added some more dates
friday october 15th
at the fox theater in atlanta um
friday october 22nd at the terrace
theater in long beach
california richard pryor's home uh
friday november 5th we got a late show
at the grand
sierra resort and casino in one of my
favorite cities rito
uh saturday november 6th the late show
at san jose
center for for the performing arts my
[ __ ] jokes are going to be in a
performing arts center how funny is that
friday november 12th at the fox theater
in detroit uh tickets will be on sale at
billberg.com
tour thank you
and god bless america hey what's going
on everybody and welcome to the thursday
afternoon just before friday monday
morning podcast
uh where i yours truly checks in on you
to see how your
uh work week is going and every once in
a while
i have special guests
only and uh this right now this is what
i mean i've always excited for guests
but this is like crazy
we have the incredible drum one of the
greatest drummers i'm going to embarrass
you here
uh on the planet mr benny greb
who has written a book effective
practicing for musicians which is green
so it's not going to show up here you
got it here
benny there you go he's holding up
this book is so freaking amazing that
i'm actually applying
the tools on how to effectively practice
drums
to trying to get my instrument rating as
a pilot
and it's it's it's paying dividends and
uh first of all i just want to say
welcome
oh man thanks for having me that's
awesome thanks where where are you right
now are you in uh
germany yeah hamburg germany where i'm
where i live
all right well let's let's let's jump
right in i've only read the first like
40 pages
because i have 80d and i'm all over the
place and all i all i've done
is like like even like draw everything
about it like the whole
like when you sit there and you think
that you're practicing for an hour
right like i'm going to play drums for
an hour every single day and blah blah
blah you always hear those guys oh i
play for six
hours i play i practice six hours a day
yeah you break it down where you
actually like recorded yourself
right i'm in the practice room to see
like how much
you were practicing and you realized
that in like you had it for like
90 minutes or something that that you
realize that you only were actually
practicing so for it was some really
small amount of time how much was it was
yeah it was embarrassing
embarrassingly small yeah thanks for
pointing that out
listen you'd get frustrated and do like
angry fills which was my favorite thing
ever because i do that
i've been trying i've been trying to get
that john bonham triplet think down
my whole life and that's what i do
practice for a little bit
i'd get angry i'd do so this is triplet
thing and then i would move
on to something else and then wonder why
i could never
catch up so what started what's how how
did this come about
and and then i just want to get into how
you were nice enough to share it with
everybody so
at what point did you hit a place with
your drumming where you were just like
i am just not move was it were you just
feeling like i wasn't moving forward at
the pace i wanted
we just frustrated with your playing
what was it
all of it i mean yeah
first of all i think i found out when i
started to go to music college
uh uh to really study music i had to
move away from home
and i was 17 i was the youngest there
had no life skills
at all which i then found out i couldn't
cook pasta i couldn't wash my own
clothes i was like oh my god this is
horrible
and i then to make it even worse found
out like the one thing i thought i was
kind of decent at because i was the i
i came there in terms of like oh wow i'm
the best drummer in my village
because i was the only one and then i
came
to music college and all of a sudden i
was the little guy and i realized
oh holy [ __ ] i have to have to step my
game up because of course
um finally there were everyone was as
nerdy as me
where before i was an anomaly i listened
to
a lot of american and english music and
blah blah so i had all of that going on
that
how did you push through that because
that i feel that's a critical
point for anybody that is is going after
something
when you are sort of you're the funniest
guy in your class
or the best drummer in on your street or
whatever and all of a sudden
you know and that's your whole universe
and then you show up and the first time
you meet somebody oh my god this guy's
funnier these guys
comedy longer than me and these guys
been playing drum along and and like
that's a real blow to the ego
yeah um and i i think it causes some
people to quit
yeah i mean thankfully and i think
probably the comedy scene is it can be
pretty harsh at times or something but
uh for me it wasn't that kind of
whiplash horror
scenario it wasn't like a hardcore like
everyone was
pretty much very friendly and so so the
the the amount of like people also
like helping me out and and me being
excited about being in this new
environment of like oh my god
um it was amazing they had all these
record books
there they had all the resources there
they had each this huge library
of all the stuff that i never could get
before i heard of it
but i never knew how like that that was
before the internet right
so again i'm there excited
about getting like sort of humbled of
like
oh wow man i thought access
i had access to all of this great stuff
that i was interested in anyway for the
first time in my life before it was
it was like seemed uh it seemed already
awkward like in this little bavarian
village to try to become
like whatever i saw in the musicians i
liked and uh
so who are you listening to when who
would like you who are your favorite
drum because
when i listen to you play you have such
like your own style
um yeah i don't really necessarily be
like
oh or this guy is a tony williams guy
or you know the the you know the little
i know about drumming
you come in here come on
uh comedian i do but not for uh
for like a drummer what i
loved stuart copeland i i absolutely my
brother
had an unusual music taste for that time
and
that area and he listened to all this a
lot of 70s like
uh i mean he had bg's records and he had
the jimi hendrix thing
and tower of power james brown
and the police which i which i could get
into easily because
the early albums were very punky and i
that i really liked that and
they were kind of responsible for me to
to grab me
by the hand and gently lead me to all
time signatures and
and like all the sting pop kind of
vinnie
and all this kind of universe and uh
that was one of the one of the things
yeah now were you
were you blessed with an ear where you
could figure out it's like some of those
um
with stewart copeland i've always loved
him but i never even attempted any and
maybe like
roxanne or whatever and even then when
they went to the the rocks and
part that whole weird no i think it was
the the verse was the part that would
screw me up
um i once he really started doing all
that crazy stuff with the hi-hats
yeah and then he he opened him up real
quick and in weird times
and just his whole feel and everything
was just so
alien yeah romance so i would just
listen to it be blown away and
i don't think i ever even attempted to
try and play so how did you like
was you just born with those ears you
could no no no no around the record
yeah i i i listened it a million times i
had this cd changer thingy
and in the base my dad
that's why i also lived in in the us for
a while then back then he had something
because he worked for this american
company as well
and uh they introduced something that
was very hip back then in germany no one
has ever heard it before totally new
concept it was called
home office which is a great idea
but not so great if you have a little
punk drama at home
so every once in a while although my
parents i have to say we're super super
supportive
but every once in a while my dad
just came home and said like are you
[ __ ] crazy
like completely because he just couldn't
get any work done because i had these
challenges and i did that with the
police there
is a cd set uh called message in a box
where all the recordings of the police
like a cd set like in the booklet thingy
and i had this cd changer and one of my
challenges was like how many times in a
row
i can play through the whole program
like
without like passing out or
how long would that take hours yeah it
was a day or
you know like like yeah took a while
yeah yeah yeah i mean i'm very grateful
for for their support i mean god knows
how they did it my mother was basically
my
my back liner so to speak i had a i had
a cover band when
when i didn't know did you were you
during during those times did you have a
uh when you were in just in your small
town and you were in
your parents basement or whatever or in
the house wherever your little studio
was did you take lessons were you were
you were a lessons guy
i was using the lessons guy no um i i
was completely out to deduct uh as they
say or self-taught
um and uh
because the first attempt was oh the kid
is
you know motivated and he wants to bang
on things and i played trumpet and piano
first
with lessons but the drums were always
the sexiest to me
i always thought like but this is it i
don't want to do that
i want to do that and
and then we had this umpa band this
local oompa man every village
has one right and i later played trumpet
in that band as well
but um so we went to this drama guy
which is the guy that runs around with
the big drum
like in front of his belly right that's
a symbol
the oktoberfest is how we know that
those types of ants yes
exactly i mean we lived like half an
hour or an hour from munich so that
that's the
and so my mom like
was like ah he's a drummer so let's ask
him for lessons
and so we went down to this community
center thing where also the
oh damn i don't have the vocabulary for
it like the guys that
shoot animals like the hunters yeah
the guy said shoot animals yes
i'm blown away that you can speak
languages it's a more than one it's
amazing
i'll help you wherever you need so yeah
i need all the help i can get
um you know all the hunters were there
so there were all these like elk
heads like coming out of the wall like
on these on these wooden boards and
stuff
but that was also the place where the
local umber band was rehearsing
and we had an appointment with the guy
and my mom came with me oh she's so
amazing and
only like a mom could like the door
opened and it looked like a fog machine
was in there like from the 80s or
something because the guy was chained
smoking like with
yellow fingers and yellow beard he had a
white beard but it was yellow around the
and and my mom was so enthusiastic and
she said like oh so that's benny and
when he listens to music he dances
around and
he did he doesn't like the [ __ ] like
like mallets and timpani he doesn't like
that [ __ ] but he likes to play the drums
and we we hoped you could
and the guy was listening to his
chainsmoking patiently
and then turned over to me and said the
first
three years we will only play the
snare drum and i'm like
wow oh god and i said
sabos which is the bavarian for sia
and uh she said that right then oh you
thought i was
no i was so traumatized that i didn't
want to have any lessons for the next
six years
so that's that's that was lessons out of
the picture for me
so i only learned through cds and my own
thing but
to come back to your beginning question
that's why it also was completely messed
up i made some kind of progress but
i mean to be honest i later found out
i called practicing quote-unquote
the process of or for me it was
practicing as soon i was in the same
room
as the drums right so the
all the pizza eating and star trek next
generation watching
got got thrown into the prac so-called
practice time
so that's what's so incredible about
this book is because one of the hardest
things
you know when you're trying something
new or you're trying to get
good at something is you what what
feeds you is improvement progress
and what really just makes you you give
up hope
and makes the light seem like it's
disappearing you're never gonna get to
the end of the tunnel
is is when you're just sort of like in
like uh an eddie you know just spinning
around and spinning around
um i i
find it amazing that uh
someone of your drumming abilities
has basically written the book on like
the secrets on like
how you can apply this just the stuff
that
that did you've had in this book as far
as like
recording yourself and trying to figure
out how much of this is actually
practicing and then also allowing part
of your practice time
to now you just get to play and have fun
and who gives a [ __ ] if you screw it
up i've been able to like
you know like really go in there like
like today
i was reading the part of your book
where you were saying like
make it like your practice room just
like you want to be in there
right and everything's ready to go and
it's not like oh i gotta change the
heads or i gotta
i gotta put this thing back up like i
walk into my drum room now
i sit down put on headphones and i'm
playing
and it's just like ready to go it just
it's yeah the friction thing
where you were talking about getting rid
of all of this friction so i had these
two podcasts to do today
and normally i was but i only had like a
half hour to play this is how much your
book's helping me i only had a half hour
to play
and i had these two podcasts in this
zoom meeting that i had to do before
that
and normally i'd be like oh god i mean
by the time i get out there
what i did was i set up all my podcast
[ __ ] first
i had i turned my car around because in
between i was gonna have time to run out
and get a [ __ ]
sandwich so i had everything ready to go
and then i made another thing too that
kills my practice is if i don't
stretch before i get in there oh because
all of these years of like riding in
cars and sitting on my ass and
everything
i'll have circulation problems with my
legs unless i stretch so if i stretch
out
you know and then you know if i don't
stretch sometimes one of my feet might
get a little tingly
and then and then i don't play as well
and then i get frustrated then i stop so
i did all of that and i went downstairs
and even after the stretching i still
had 20
minutes and it was 20 killer minutes
right
and i felt like i picked up the big rock
and i moved it
a little bit closer and i walked out of
there my mood
i was in a great mood i had a great
meeting i like to think i'm having good
podcasts and
that's effective practicing for
musicians i'm applying this now
to the instrument thing which is total
egghead
genius [ __ ] and i'm a dope so i really
have to like
know but now i have it like you know
like my flash cards i got everything all
like laid out
so i can just literally you could like
wheel me in
like hannibal lecter sit down i hit the
button and then i'm on my simulator
doing it so um
so that's because it's all the same
stuff isn't it like like
i mean the body has a certain the body
and the brain
i mean has a certain programming
language that either works and there are
certain things we
we can do that definitely won't work
and yeah because i mean one of the
things with the book was
um although there is a big part where we
try to find out like
where we try to really specifically find
out okay what is
the right thing to do what is the next
thing to do and
and that automatically means all the
other things i don't have to do
now so so that increases focus and
and gives you also something to
accomplish because if you always think
like oh my god there is so much stuff
but um but it also keeps you
if you have that focus you're not
stressed and then when you're relaxed
you play better and you sound better and
yeah
one of the things that it took me so
long
dave elich my drum teacher out here
shout out to dave
yeah he taught me i remember growing up
all of us were trying to have that big
bottom sound and we were swinging like
thinking you had to do that even though
when
we had sound reigns this song remains
the same
and you watched him and he was never
doing that he was he was down here
it was just he was totally relaxed he
was hitting the drum and he was getting
out of the way and letting the thing
sing
and get back to the helicopter thing
is like when you fly an instrument you
have to be so precise you're like
if they tell you to hold an altitude you
can't be off by more than 100 feet you
know when there's like turbulence and
stuff a helicopter
is inherently unstable it's not like
flying a plane
so i'm like was holding on like this
and the guy you don't want to do that
you want to be like
fingertips just like with drumsticks oh
wow and
you want to be barely holding on almost
feeling like it's going to fall out of
your hand
it sounded like when i was talking to
dave when he was telling me how to hold
drumsticks hit the drum get out of the
way
so what it is it's counter-intuitive
because you think like you have more
control when you grip
tight and and you have it and but yeah
and what it becomes
is yeah then any movement in your
shoulder is yanking that thing over and
now you're
you're off course so it's like literally
broke it down where he was saying like
this thing like the corrections are are
minuscule
and what you're doing is just sort of
just little things like that and it all
flying
is is is just little corrections
right when he broke it down like that
like
and it was one lesson in the whole way i
fly now
i used to just you know and i had like
now there's nothing with like my legs
and stuff i think it was because
flying you're thinking like don't die
don't die when you're when you're
soloing or whatever
you're doing [ __ ] like it it got like
we all like tensed up and i had like a
masseuse and everything to work this
[ __ ] out it was all
from being like tense and
um this book has helped me get
even with after the stuff dave taught me
this book has helped me to get
even like more relaxed so i wanted to
talk about when you got to this when you
got to the school
and you're realizing like hey man i was
the big fish
i was the best ump drummer in my little
town and you
you got there that sounds so depressing
it's very accurate yeah
well i wasn't even the funniest kid in
most of my classes so there's hope for
everybody
um when i was growing up but like
when you were first you know
uh after six years of playing for hours
and hours and hours and hours driving
your dad crazy occasionally
yeah like you had all of this muscle
memory
that you now had to undo so even with
your your
inefficient way of playing yeah and
you're still feeling like you're not as
good as everybody else
you're gonna have to take an even more
step back
so-called get worse what was that like
for you at that age to
um be like oh man so even even my little
bag of tricks that i'm bringing here i
have to i have to unlearn and then
relearn that
just to get to the level of being like
feeling like i'm i'm at the bottom of
this barrel here it
it kind of fit um in a way because i
realized that
i came up i came a certain way with my
with my abilities but i also hit certain
walls and certain plateaus where i'm
like it's
obviously not it's obviously not working
i can't do this
i have to change something um and then
of course
you think oh there will be a next step
and the next step will be
something like amazing and blah
and then you get confronted with
fundamentals again and and that
that feels always like a step back i
think jojo maya once put it best when
uh i think he talked about like this you
build a skyscraper or a house
so you have a fundament that you built
that's kind of solid it has a certain
like uh um certain area
that it is then you build on top of it
you build on top of it
so the fundament and then skills on top
of it
if you build higher and higher and
higher and that is your game to be like
oh
something new something flashy here
something nice there
at some point the building or your
abilities and skills become so high that
it
kind of becomes unstable and kind of
begins to wobble a little bit
and then what you have to do is to climb
all the way down
make the fundament broader and stronger
then you can build up again till the
point becomes
wobbly again then you have to go down
again
and you build the fundament stronger so
you so to understand that this is a
constant
thing when when you get higher and
higher and it's not it's not a failure
it's actually progress to say like oh
wow
i'm at this point already where
where my skill level now becomes shaky
and i have to work on the fundamentals
again
but now with different knowledge a
different background different scope new
abilities of course and um
and i think i was confronted with that
as well
but it was a good thing and of course
what you're talking about is this
frustrating feeling of
when you attack something new or you go
to the fundaments
and you really do open heart surgery
there
then then you enter this in between zone
where the old stuff doesn't work anymore
and the new stuff doesn't work yet and
you feel like you play with
like like gloves or something it's like
oh my god
what have i done uh and but
when you're in one of those periods and
you have a live gig
yeah horrible you're horrible oh you yes
i was gonna say can you just like forget
about it and then go player
or you just have to kind of go out and
not be as good
yeah yeah oh wow you try to be
you try to do the best i mean uh um but
sometimes
uh it also helps you to put the focus on
something else so if you're really
struggling with
or you're working on your technique or
on certain things
and you maybe have been drilling down
and focusing on that sometimes gigs can
also help you then to be like
ah but then i had to listen to the songs
and the song form and
and um and i'm sure a book that dave
also told you about this inner game of
tennis
which which works about there's this
tennis coach that
that worked basically teaches movement
without letting his students focus on
the movement
because the body kind of does it itself
so he he kind of distracts them and says
like listen to the ball blah blah
blah blah the rhythm that the ball takes
right then move
sideways to and then kind of the body
also does a couple of things then by
itself
although in my experience
for me it was very very helpful with the
recordings
with the journaling to really take a
look at what i'm doing
because i didn't do that for so so long
before i studied music
that then it was a shock to me that what
i
thought i was doing and what i was
actually doing
was miles apart and but
it's like the first time you hear your
voice recorded and played back to you
you're like that's what i sound like
yeah yeah i um dave forever was trying
to get me to start
regularly videotaping myself which i'm
still not the best at because it's just
so it's just so disappointing
it's oh it's it's it's never like oh i
thought it was here and i'm here it's
like i
i thought it was here and i'm down on
the floor um
i you know fascinates me as far as like
you know
doing shows myself is nights when i'm
off
um i i like i go on stage and i'm just
i'm just [ __ ] like it's like if in
your world it's like you're
you're you're just a little in front of
that you're rushing or you're dragging
right and comedy there's a lot of
similarities to that where you just
you know you're not in this zone you
know and it's it's like
the nights when you're on and you hit a
zone it's effortless you
barely have to do your act you feel like
you've been on stage for 10 minutes and
an hour went by what happened my god it
was like a
walk in the park and then there's other
nights when you're tired
you know or just there's just some weird
energy in the room and you give into it
it's you start feeling like you're
shoveling wet snow
and and so i learned
uh there's a couple of tricks that i do
to get to trick myself
into being present in the room
and then getting like lined up with the
crowd
so i can have the best show possible so
they won't feel like they got like
ripped
off and um you know a lot of it is
i'll start improvising on all of my
jokes
because then it's new i'm taking a
chance
even if you're insecure and or or maybe
you're not insecure but if you realize
it doesn't really
kind of go the way you want you are
fearless enough to
to just be like okay let's break this
[ __ ] up not fearless i
the the feeling of not having fun
doing stand-up comedy is one of the
worst feelings you're ever going to have
i can't
like because you aren't worried about
yourself almost well because you're
miserable in your job stay
make everybody laugh and it's the exact
opposite of what you're feeling it's
like it's a it's a it's really like
messes with your mind so yeah what what
i did
was i will overly act out stuff i'll act
sillier and more stupid and usually what
happens is
if it doesn't make me laugh it's to hit
somebody in the crowd
my silliness and it makes them laugh and
their laugh
literally is like battery power
and then it just sort of i can't think
about it too much or i screw it up
right but it it gets it back to where
now
um um i'm moving along here and
i was wondering as like a a drummer
where can i ask you something first
about that yes yes
but but did you also had
experiences where you thought like oh my
god this is hard work today this
nothing works and blah blah and then
maybe you record it yourself and you
realize afterwards it wasn't that
wasn't that bad or the other way around
where you thought like man tonight is
amazing
and then you listen to it i've never
thought it was amazing and it wasn't
it wasn't i grew up catholic so you
never give yourself credit for anything
i've definitely had german overview
where i've just been like man that was
[ __ ] terrible and they were like what
are you talking about was one of your
best sets i've seen
and then what i used to think is like oh
they don't know what they're talking
it's because they don't know comedy
but then i kind of realized that um
sometimes
when i was frustrated especially when i
was younger
the frustration caused me to slow down
and like if you watch me early on
in most of my stand up that's recorded i
am going just a little too fast
just every song the tempo would be just
a little too
if the jokes there were songs they would
be just a little too fast and
it took me a long time to really
like i mean the first eight years i was
on stage uh
so much of my movement was just nervous
energy
right so not only drumming though
yeah it was like a distraction and like
i'd be out of breath like you guys like
you blow yourself out in two songs
like [ __ ] i got a whole set to play here
the same thing would happen with like j
i would be out of breath
i'd be doing again like a guest spot
like a 12-minute spot i'd be eight
minutes in
like winded like i would like i was on
like a stair master or something and it
was just all
adrenaline is a hell of a drug yeah
adrenaline is
so how do you how on on nights when it
just sounds like you're
to you it sounds like you're falling
down the stairs with your drum kit
is there a like what i was talking about
how okay i can be
impro improvise you know act out the
punch lines more
get sillier or whatever lock in on an
audience members laugh
what do you do as a musician it's always
fascinated me how
you uh get out of something like that
um um maybe it sounds stupid but a lot
of experience helps me
where i when i'm on a tour it's it's
actually
it's probably the same with you it's the
best thing to learn because you can from
one evening to the next
see little changes and be like oh
yesterday ah i will never do that again
and you
kind of like adjust a little bit and
then
when you record but it's the same when
you record
or journal with your practicing you
you collect all these pieces of
information all this experience of data
where you're like
oh gosh i thought i'd make it i mean a
classic for drummers is
oh i'll make it i make it nice and
intense and i'll go to the china
and i'll just back the [ __ ] out of this
thing
this the lead singer already has chinese
drumming version of a [ __ ] joke for us
all right i'll go bodily fluid here this
will get him
yes and the lead thing is already
bleeding out of his ears and
and you're like oh this is so intense
and then on the
on the recording it it sounds small it
just sounds small because it's only high
frequency there's nothing like
and you think like oh no and then you
realize
the hi-hat has much more power that's
why all these punk bands have
had like there's so much bark so much
and you do that and you think ah and
when you when you had
received this pain once this shame of
like listening to a recording and think
like
oh my god it's like acting out like
being drunk or something
and you can't connect to how it actually
comes out anymore
you think you're maybe amazing and
you're super funny
and then afterwards you realize oh gosh
like i'm making a fool out of myself
and it feels the same way because it's
it's it's expression
as well it's when you play a musical
instrument it's even worse with singing
but it's with drumming the same
where it feels like you're expressing
yourself and if you don't
have a certain effect you feel
ineffective
and and stupid and in that pain
if you then can be like oh wow that hurt
then you will find yourself on stage
again and then it comes up again and you
feel like
okay i'm gonna give more energy and then
you think
oh no i know this it feels
right now it feels right now but
it won't come out like it feels now i
know this from experience although it's
counter-intuitive
so this helps me a lot to be like okay i
now
want to do this phil but i know that
this is too much
i just know it
this will get me fired i will not do it
i'll keep playing the hi-hat
have you ever gotten fired um
that's a no you would have remembered
i mean never blatantly no but
but of course like there are shows where
or there are maybe bands where then
someone else plays afterwards or
something
and and you think like oh but no
not not yeah but of course i had phases
where like
when i had my stuart copeland phase when
i started music
god knows how many ballads i destroyed
by trying to
be stuart copeland you know with
splashes like
like a like a like a loud backbeat and
the poor singers were like oh geez um
all right i have a question i got a
question for you as far as something
that
really fascinates me about high level
musicians
which you are is
how you go you go about learning
how uh to play
what you hear or play what you feel
versus
oh here's a lick right right left
kick kick blah blah blah just do that a
thousand times and
because there is a dis there's a
difference between
going around voicing the same lick all
around the kit
and sounding like you're doing you know
to someone like my ears i'm like
did he just play every rudiment out
there it's like no it's the same thing i
just voiced it all around the kit
and that is like uh just going bicycle
bicycle bicycle bicycle plaster bike
they're just saying the same thing all
over right yeah to
being able to especially on the drums to
be like
i'm sad today or i'm frustrated today
because with comedy like like last night
i went on stage and it was in and i was
in a dark mood
i was just in a dark mood and
it just came out it was still funny
but it came out dark and i said to
people i said sorry man i'm in a dark
mood this is going to be a little weird
which is something that i learned early
on
when you is you address the situation
don't let them sit there all
uncomfortable like what the [ __ ] unless
that's what you're going for
like a sample really just work that
uncomfortableness
so like how like when when
you're on a tour and you're just sick of
being out there
right and you're feeling this can you
use that
the way a comedian can be like i am so
sick of being on tour
i'm just going to [ __ ] roast this
town that i'm in
talk about how bad i want to go home and
everybody's going to laugh
you know as long as you're good-natured
about it like how are you able to do
that
or hear somebody in the band
play something that inspires you
like oh not over here over that that
color or whatever is over here
and to just be and just not overthink it
and just sort of let your body do it
like how does that
is is there a way to work on because
i've been doing a thing with dave where
it's just like he goes sing a phil
which is the most embarrassing thing
i know but to do it with another human
being like in a room like that who's
an exceptional drummer it's just you
feel and he says he goes don't you're
gonna
feel stupid and you're like okay you're
like
he's like all right start with that you
know
you feel like you feel all of a sudden
you go from like man i'm getting like
some of this really good [ __ ] and you
immediately just feel like one of those
clapping monkeys with like the with the
symbols
but that's what that's my job actually
like that's a good job description i'm a
clapping monkey with like
i'm hitting things i saw this bbc
documentary recently where this
where there was this document there this
gorilla
and he was like in a certain mood and he
took a piece of wood and like
like banged it on the ground and my
girlfriend's like look that's
that's you it's like
[Laughter]
just jamming with other like i've always
been like just so envious when i see
like one of those things where you see
just a bunch of drummers around they're
playing they're trading fours or
whatever
or some of those
you mentioned a couple of different
things the the the first thing is of
course
you can adjust uh to the to feelings of
the room but no one knows that
and can do that better than you where
you and you can do it verbally when i'm
a band leader in my band moving parts
i do uh like i am
silly and i do stupid jokes and i and i
and i say like oh
gosh like what's going on today and and
you connect with the audience that way
and
and especially when you play music that
is um
like like jazz or that some people might
fear
high brow it is very powerful to be a
silly bastard in between
it's it's amazing dizzy gillespie always
did that i mean it's it was
it's just amazing like if you have great
stuff not
that i'm saying that i'm an example of
it but if you have great great great
great musicians
doing right neck breaking things and
then
there is this looseness about it and oh
it's amazing but anyways
because my favorite comedians my
favorite can be are super smart
comedians that are silly
yeah jim norton patrice uh rest his
soldiers all of these guys that i've
seen
that like they're just like like
like jim norton has one of the quickest
minds of anybody i've ever been around
and he's one of the
silliest human beings yeah
self-deprecating
and all of that so that's amazing norm
mcdonald who
who like like playing the dumb guy kind
of stuff
oh yeah they're playing yeah this is and
then he does that
grin that that legend if you get what
he's doing
all right so so i don't drive people
nuts because i i always sort of plow
forward and i
don't let a lot of guests answer enough
questions so so then how do you
how do you like the next thing start to
be able to learn how to
play ideas that you're hearing as you're
doing i mean what do you set the
metronome to for me it's like minus ten
it's bpm
so you you when you play yeah anyway
uh
it's it's it's like i i love to compare
that to language um
and it is language because you have
building blocks of things
that you of course can focus on and
maybe have to look at and and can
get a feel for it like letters or words
i mean english is not my first language
so so i had to kind of be like
house house h-o-u-s
okay but of course
i will not be able to express myself
properly
uh until i see a house and i
feel house i feel that that
is the thing i i don't have to say the
word
this is a house right so you connect the
emotion of what you're seeing
uh smartphone blah blah blah and
that's what it is and and it's the same
with
where certain sounds and and maybe like
um
certain movements that that i think get
put into like little categories
that fit certain emotions or certain
intensities right where it's like
you know it's like i now want to scream
kind of
on the drums now i need er i need high
energy and then you have certain
stuff for that that's the thick ass
floor tom
sound that you have yeah exactly exactly
or you have like the biggest
sound i've ever heard oh thanks i love
it what do you say you want to you
want to sound like you want your floor
toms to sound like you
you just slapped a dead pig what is it
nothing yes yeah yeah
but but i want it to feel like gigantic
yeah we were we were at guitar center on
14th street or something new york and i
happened to be in town
and you were gonna do a um a clinic and
i i went down and i got to watch you
tune drums
right and like i just remember when you
started hitting that floor tom every
drummer that worked in there
came in which it was what was funny was
they were saying can i buy that drum off
for you
yeah which the real question is is like
can you teach me how to do that
right so my tom can sound i i can i
might want to take you a sound but i
want to get
that like i mean that is just
that that face that is there on your
stank face
tank faces yeah that is where that is at
yeah
um
so in this book i guess if i apply
things in this book because i always
felt like
um you know i get obsessed with [ __ ]
and i was and i wanted to be like
you know i would want to be just at this
point i would just love to be able to
play with somebody
they played you know some fours and i
was able to just just
one time just be just be relaxed
and not have something already memorized
like no matter what you say i'm saying
that i'm saying bicycle
that's what the [ __ ] i'm doing right
like and it's just that so
fascinates me uh and i think that it
really separates
the same thing with comp comedians like
i think there
there is a there is doing your act
and then there's this other level where
you are present in the room
and like like when i go on i don't have
a set list
it's even if i write one down wow i walk
out and that thing
is out the win it's mostly i'm just
writing it down so i can look at it and
i
those are my jokes and then i go out
there
and i want to walk out thinking nothing
right which is impossible just walking
out
now sometimes i'll sing a stupid song to
myself i'm just trying to just
just whatever you do i heard vinnie call
you to say it one time thinking is the
enemy and i never forgot
he said that and that's literally if you
want
to perform at the height of your
abilities the last thing you want to be
is between your ears
which to use your expression
counter-intuitive it makes no sense
because you think like
i need to perform my best so i must be
thinking out everything
that i'm doing and i my favorite thing
is to watch
musicians or comedians who i they're
like
this person they just flowing you coming
at me this way
i'm gonna move this way and then i'm
gonna come back around here it's not
like well you're pushing me this way but
i'm just gonna lean in because no matter
what i
i am i'm doing this right and i'm not
flexible i i i
have my set ways i have planned it this
way and but that's why when i when i see
your perform
when i see you perform it i get the same
feeling like when i see a great jazz
musician perform
because it's it's like you say it's this
difference of
when i'm about ready to not off and fall
off the stage
in an old shirt no that's not what i
mean no
what i mean it's the difference the
crowd's ready to nod off
sorry i'm not good with compliments i
appreciate it
you have to take it i'm sorry but uh
but i think it's that difference of
doing
versus being more a kind of like here
here i am that's just who i am instead
of like okay let me do this
one thing then the next thing and and uh
yeah that's what i said to dave i i
after four years of
of intermittently taking lessons within
five years i finally
came to the epiphany that i didn't play
drums i do drums
and i was just like i have to stop doing
drums
and and and i i was able to apply that
you know in other areas but like i just
i don't know so but
my thing was is i would always say you
know i just don't have the time i just
don't have the time i just don't have
time which is why i love this book
because i i have 20 minutes a day
yeah get out there and it also it puts
me in a good mood so i'll be a better
dad and a husband makes my life
less friction and all of that so um
i had the quickest hour of my of my week
here we're coming up on here so i just
want to i want to promote this before uh
we start to wrap up here it's effective
practicing for
musicians written by benny greb it's the
ultimate guide for how to become
better at your instrument so this is not
just drums
this is whatever you're doing or
whatever your instrument is i'm getting
an instrument
rating hopefully and i am using this
book
and um it's it's
so commendable of you where you know a
lot of people get to your level there
becomes an insecurity and you don't want
to share your secrets
and i think it says a lot about you that
you would sit there and be like this is
exactly how i got to where
i am right now because i'm telling you
man like you like
for the listeners how i got to know
about you was just
you know i am a drum nerd and i was just
went down this rabbit hole i can't
remember where i first saw you if it was
on one of those modern drummer things or
whatever
but um or maybe you put out a dvd
because back then i bought all of them
uh the language of drumming maybe yeah
language drama yeah i i definitely had
that i don't i think maybe i i saw you
on youtube and then i bought it
and uh i first was like hi this guy from
europe and he's playing a sonar kit
these guys are always good
[Laughter]
these guys that play these drum kits
always seemed to be good and it was also
like uh
even the only two other drop like i
guess steve smith is only like the
really like a only american drummer that
i really know
that played sonar of course phil rudd
but he's uh
australian guy um but i just knew
no wait did uh who was that
um that degenerated well i saw him at
the
uh the amount of dramas great drummers
that i've seen
that i had no idea what they were doing
i saw jack dijonette at the half shell
in um massachusetts right on steroid
drive i saw him in 1990
i saw tony williams oh man i saw tony uh
you should have been there your ears
should have hurt not mine i just knew he
was awesome but
i saw him at this place the regatta bar
that held maybe 125 people and during
his breaks
you could just walk up and be peeking
behind
that yellow drum kit with the gretch kit
with the three floor toms and the
uh the black dots and and like
and since then i've become such a tony
williams freak
and and mostly like his solos
yeah are like songs his his
composition um he has one solo i feel
like it's a drum lesson
where he just starts and he's on the
snare forever yeah
and you're like is this what this is
going to be and then he just
incorporates
the first rack tom and then he's kind of
going back and forth little mingle in
there
and then he does the two and then he
brings the whole thing in and right as
you blow he's
blowing your mind then he brings in the
symbols it was just like
just an absolute uh master and i'm
telling you man
you're like there's this like you you
the way you perform is a very
you're in rare air and i just i just
want to thank you for coming on the
podcast
doing what you do like like you
literally like i i'm a weird guy like i
i become a better comedian watching a
great drummer
i don't know why that is it gets
inspiring like
i like because i always try to equate it
to that because i'm a failed musician
i remember talking to a buddy of mine a
long time ago saying like
you know what i really wish i could just
have somebody come over and play guitar
at the level i'm doing comedy because
it's so hard to understand
where you are as like a comedian like
because you know you go down the club
everybody's killing
people are dying laughing and then like
they come up to you like
like oh my god you were so funny and
then they start telling you
somebody else's joke like it's like that
wasn't me that was the other guy
so it's really hard to kind of gauge
where you're at
so um anyways i'm going to talk to you
forever it's effective practicing for
musicians
written by benny greb this book will
change your life man thank you so much
for writing this and thank you so much
for coming on the podcast
and i don't know what time it is over
there i imagine it's
extremely late or early it's midnight
now oh midnight that's not too bad
that's not too bad
right hey thank you so much it's very
generous of you thank you so much for
letting me come on
don't worry all right everybody the
great benny greb check it out effective
practicing for musicians
mack weldon everybody you know this year
spring is going to be is going to hit
a little different because we are all
finally starting to get back
outside and seeing our friends again no
matter where your adventures take you
bring the comfort and style of mac
weldon along for the ride
trust me your closet is going to thank
you
whether it's their hoodies polos uh
tees or active shorts everything in mac
welding
the mac welding collection mixes and
matches seamlessly
to fit in with any other trendy products
you have
men's essentials like socks shirts
hoodies polos or active shorts
mack weldon promises comfort and a
consistent
fit versatility you look great
you feel great from working out going
out going to work or on a date mac
weldon
is for everyday life you think that's my
last example no it isn't
technology wide range of customized
fabrics that can keep up with you no
matter what your day looks like
weldon blue totally free loyalty program
level one gets you free shipping for
life
once you reach level two by spending two
hundred dollars
you get twenty percent off every order
for the next year from twenty percent
off your first order
visit mac weldon m-a-c-k-w-e-l-d
dot com slash burr and enter the promo
code bird that's maxweldon.com
promo code code burr for 20 off mac
weldon
reinventing men's basics you know what's
crazy
i just realized remember when when you
were
nice enough to invite uh i brought my
band over like in vancouver when you
played that show in vancouver
oh yeah that was my last gig
that was my last that was like my last
inside gig
oh i wish we remembered to say that is
it still recording
you can put this on as an apple log yeah
dude my last my last gig
that i did that was like in the normal
world
yeah um yeah that was i was in vancouver
and i was so
thrilled that you guys and somehow for
some reason just the way my show lined
up i couldn't go and see you guys
because you know what's crazy i've never
all these years i've known you i've
never seen you play live how nuts is
that
hey when this whole when this whole crap
is over
or it comes down a little bit i'll come
to your house and tune your drums
[Music]
[Applause]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday april 8th
2013. how you doing how are you
today's podcast episode is brought to
you by ting
please visit bill.ting.com for
25 service credit or device discount
that's bill.tingting.com
and i know what you're thinking bill
what the hell is ting
what is it you can't just bring up a
product and
and i don't even know what it is you
know it's got that ambiguous name what's
going on with it well ting is a new
mobile service that brings clarity
usability and significant monthly
savings to u.s
small businesses and families so
basically if you're tired of paying an
arm and a leg
for your cell phone bill every month you
should check out ting they just added a
new 3g
slash 4g wimax hotspot to the ting
lineup
the sierra wireless overdrive pro can be
had and refurbished for only 30 bucks
in february they added the option to
purchase used devices via their
partnership with glide
the option to bring a sprint device has
been around for a while but there was a
limitation
no lte devices could make the move well
they've been working to have this
limitation removed and now many lte
sprint devices are able to make the move
to ting
port your home port i don't even know
what that means port your home phone
number to ting
and save a mint if you like us barely
use the home phone
but aren't quite ready to let it go this
100 device can bridge the gap
and save you a ton versus traditional
wired home phone services
you know what i actually might check
that out because i barely use my home
phone but i refuse to give it up
you know why because i'm part of the old
school
i am when i'm on the phone i wear a
headband you get it
[ __ ] old school sorry um
anyways they have excellent online
support anytime you got a problem you
can call them at one
eight five five ting ftw
anytime between 8 a.m and 8 p.m eastern
standard time and believe it or not a
real person will actually pick up the
phone
all right so please visit bill.ting.com
for a 25
service credit and dis device discount
there we go
i almost got through without stuttering
all right
so here we go this is the monday morning
podcast everybody and i am in
atlanta atlanta baby how you doing
um
i uh got here last night uh i'm a day
early before my my big showdown in
athens
georgia and uh you're probably wondering
bill why did you come in
a day and a half early well i'll tell
you why because tonight i'm going to the
basketball game michigan vs louisville
all right the ncaa championship game why
wouldn't you
you're in town there's still tickets to
be had
can you believe that there's still
tickets to be had dude atlanta has to be
the worst [ __ ] sports town
on the face of the united states i
didn't say the earth
okay i'm not gonna be arrogant and act
like i know sports fans
from here to timbuktu i don't know where
timbuktu is i don't even know if that's
a real [ __ ] place i don't know if
that's an expression
i don't know who's shot i don't know
who's not
um but they [ __ ]
suck here in atlanta
okay in atlanta they suck george
bulldogs that's a whole different story
hey wait
you give me no damn dogs i'm in there
i'm between the hedges
okay i'm not talking about the sec
college [ __ ] sports fan down here
those people are [ __ ] lunatics
all right they're out there making
moonshine before the game they're out of
their [ __ ] minds
they're either full on [ __ ] redneck
or they're like that um
oh belvedere come here you know they
have that [ __ ] plantation vibe
one of the other just talking about the
white people down here all right
so and the drug addicts are all in the
waffle house
all right if you want to score some meth
and get a
delicious breakfast and you're in the
south i have to recommend
the [ __ ] waffle house that's the
place to go if you'd like to maybe get
into a fight
if you didn't even know that you wanted
to get into a fight that's where you
want to [ __ ] go
the waffle house is basically that would
be the south's
that's kind of there man what the [ __ ]
is is the equivalent to that
up in the north just some place we could
go out and get some food and maybe get
the [ __ ] kicked out of you
maybe get a prostitute maybe have a
heart attack
what is that the cheesecake factory you
know what i'll have to get back to you
on that one
anyway so i'm here and i'm gonna be
going to the uh the basketball game
tonight what the [ __ ] is with this chair
it's one of these [ __ ] chairs oh i
keep hitting the adjuster thing with my
calf
sorry it's not the chair's fault it's my
fault all right
you know what's great about this chair
is it's not a live person so i don't
really have to apologize to it even
though i just did
if this was a woman i have to be like
you know right now she would have her
arms crossed looking out the window
you know i just i understand that you
know
you have a lot of pressure because
you've been traveling a lot lately okay
but
this snapping and and just immediately
going to the anger um no no let me
finish
okay i think you've said enough for the
morning
you know they just say that [ __ ] just
gets you [ __ ] going
i'd have to apologize to it you know and
buy it some flowers
buy it some stuff you know
sorry chair my meaty calf
actually was hitting the adjustment
thing so it wasn't your fault it wasn't
a design fall
flaw whatever the [ __ ] i'm trying to say
what am i trying to say i'm trying to
say that i'm going to the ncaa
championship game tonight here in
atlanta and
it's not even [ __ ] sold out how
[ __ ] hilarious is that
what is wrong with the city of atlanta
you know what it is there's too much
there's too much [ __ ] in the city that
people they just don't go to the [ __ ]
too much [ __ ] and too much jesus you
know both sides of the [ __ ] rainbow
you know and they just don't go to the
goddamn games when's the last time a
braves game sold out
you know if i ran the braves you know
what i would do i'd put a [ __ ]
stripper pole out there in the goddamn
bullpen
you know so the people out here could
make it rain
in between innings and then i think
maybe i could get the stadium half
[ __ ] full
oh [ __ ] you
what the [ __ ] is this south carolina is
this like a [ __ ] phone or i got to do
well i ain't doing that
um the hell was i talking oh the
stripper
yeah dude you know what kills me about
[ __ ] atlanta braves is
they still do that tomahawk chop this
[ __ ]
and there's no passion behind this
what kind of a [ __ ] [ __ ] does that
how many tribes have said how [ __ ]
offensive that is
you know what i mean that's why that's
when i really [ __ ] hate people
when they're just like you know what he
ain't got nothing to do with that
you know that's stupid just
you know it's like people like into the
confederate flag
you know they try to say that it has
nothing to do with [ __ ] slavery
and just has to do with southern pride
give me a [ __ ] break
you know just be a [ __ ] racist just
man up and be a racist just get a nice
[ __ ] swastika
swastika tattoo right on your forehead
stop being passive aggressive
probably gonna get kicked out of this
hotel for saying this
oh [ __ ] you steve jobs with your [ __ ]
noises i heard it i
heard it i grabbed the phone i [ __ ]
reacted to it you
[ __ ] from the grave he's still a [ __ ]
i wonder whose idea he stole for that
[ __ ] thing and then passed it off as
his own as he goes out and tries to
[ __ ]
levitate with one of those cheesy
[ __ ] magicians
[ __ ] phone i hate this [ __ ] thing
you know what kills me too
is you put it on you put it on vibrate
i mean there's no way to shut it up i'm
sure there is if i read the [ __ ]
manual
you know but i don't have time for that
you read a [ __ ] cell phone manual
finally figure the thing out and then
what it's obsolete in eight months
bill quit yelling you're just lazy all
right
maybe i shouldn't be going off on the
dead guy you know that douche bags on
the cover of [ __ ]
time magazine with like albert einstein
as far as people who changed and shaped
the world
it worked their stupid advertising where
they lined themselves up with gandhi
has actually [ __ ] worked because now
the dude's dead
and on the cover of life magazine they
hit you know
jesus didn't even make the [ __ ] cover
or maybe he did
i don't know but what the [ __ ] you know
they actually had a really good picture
albert einstein they had a younger
version of him
you know where his hair wasn't all
[ __ ] gray
and he didn't have that sad look on his
face you know that look he had on his
face after he [ __ ] showed those
psychos how to
how to blow up all of japan all right
this is the cover
the cover is abraham lincoln jesus
albert einstein
martin luther king the beatles hitler
some old broad with [ __ ] up teeth uh
mother teresa
[ __ ] uh gandhi
uh jesus what the [ __ ] the name of
that guy who spent all those years in
prison
for an apartheid or whatever the [ __ ]
his name is was it william h macy
the [ __ ] is that guy's name he finally
got out his wife stuck by him and then
he
[ __ ] dumped her and then the guy who
came up with the phone
that angry look on his face what the
[ __ ] edison
what the [ __ ] is a guy's name here
sidney poitier
i'm the worst i don't [ __ ] know who
anybody is and anyways they got steve
jobs steve jobs rubbing elbows with all
those [ __ ] people
[ __ ] stupid-ass goddamn nerds cause
he did what he invented a phone
did he even invent it haven't i already
talked about this on stage
up on this silver screen
um so anyways i'm out here in [ __ ]
atlanta and i'm going to that goddamn
game tonight these stupid [ __ ] they
don't even [ __ ] sell the thing out
they're still doing that tomahawk chop
it's like why why would you do that
[Music]
didn't get the [ __ ] drum
i was just talking about this on the
regular guys morning show my brother
took a tour one time somewhere in
arizona and they were talking about how
native americans
played their drums and they would be
like they played like this they play it
like that
but at no point did they ever go
that's just some [ __ ] hollywood [ __ ]
where they hired a white guy with the
tan
maybe a little bit of a sunburn you know
to give him the reddish tinge that they
thought they
the [ __ ] indians have which i've
never understood
you ever see a real native american
there's nothing red about their skin
you know you know it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i am
goddamn [ __ ] redhead you put me out
in the sun
i will [ __ ] with any native american
apache i don't give a [ __ ] who you are
my skin will be redder than yours
i should be offended by the washington
redskins
making fun of me not you all right
just the fact that your face is on the
side of the helmet that's just a
misdirection
all right it's just another group of
people coming at
us [ __ ] redheads and you know what i
want to get in sick of it
all right i'm sick of [ __ ] coming up to
me telling me that i'm going to be
extinct
like i'm some sort of [ __ ] white
rhino
you know you're going to do you guys are
going to be gone by 2040. it's like i'm
going to be 72
in 2040. i'm still going to be here you
[ __ ] you know why
you know why i'll tell you why because i
go out to these hotels
all right oh there's another plane where
are those people going god
i always wished i was on a plane going
to some place exciting
sorry that was the inner monologue of a
woman who got married at 22.
um anyways plowing ahead here this is
why i'm going to live to be 72
because i don't stay in motels i don't
[ __ ] make speeches about how to
change the world
at least on my podcast maybe i do okay
but i'm not standing in front of [ __ ]
a zillion people
all right so no one's gonna whack me
all right i got good genes and you know
what today i go downstairs they got the
[ __ ] continental breakfast down there
they got the breakfast buffet and they
also got the whole thing you can order
from the menu
all right and what do i see down there i
see all the man-titted fat
[ __ ] who got the corner office and
they're down there getting themselves an
all-american breakfast
two three eggs any style the [ __ ]
bacon the potatoes just
well you know what they're doing they're
[ __ ] grabbing their heart by the
by the lapels huh grabbing it just go
hey [ __ ] right and then just
kneeing it right if
you if your heart had balls that's what
you're doing with that breakfast
the all-american you know what i did
i went down there like a little [ __ ]
twinkle toes all right
i was up on my on my tiptoes and i did a
little dance move and i slid into the
booth
and the lady you know
the lady came over
you know it's a waitress like i think
all
waitresses should be female
[Laughter]
even the waiters that's just a broad job
i'm a hungry man i want food to be
brought to me
there should be a woman involved in that
okay i'm traditional i'm old school
i pay for the movie i want my sandwich
made
by a woman that's a man in a fancy hat
some poor excuse for a [ __ ] pope hat
dude how far down is the [ __ ]
catholic religion
falling now that we're all they're all
the way down
they're they're in like south they had
to leave this country
they're gradually moving to the third
world just because
that they that's the last place that
people are still believe that some
bearded dude walked on water talked to a
[ __ ] bush
and then uh you know died and then came
back three days later
you know oh [ __ ] the fire engines are
coming out
i think there's a plane on fire
that is my big fear my big fear is not
dying in a plane crash it's
surviving the plane crash and then being
soaked in jet fuel and burning up
you know for a nice four second death of
and then that's it
you know you probably even hi much
higher pitched i wonder what the only
how many decibels you can actually
create if you're burning in jet fuel
it's so [ __ ] terrifying when you go
to take off you're literally just
you're in a tube of gasoline yeah bill
we get it we understand that you need a
lot of gas gee bill
do you need a lot of gas to fly across
the country wow your podcast is so
informative
oh so anyway so i'm down there and i get
the [ __ ] breakfast
okay and i could have got the [ __ ]
three eggs any style i could have got
the pancakes
or the waffles you know they do that
[ __ ] where they turn it into a dessert
they got everything but [ __ ]
chocolate frosting on them now i said
[ __ ] all that and i said to the lady
i said you know what let me get the cold
cereal
cold's cold like [ __ ] margaret
thatcher's knees
and i'm not saying that because she's
dead okay that [ __ ]
shape-shifting reptile you know
i actually think that she's george bush
like that that's like his alter egrow is
he's actually actually
egro ego he's actually also margaret
thatcher
you know just a theory just something to
kick around in a bar
i think they're all the same person you
know and they shoot all the world
leaders all in the same living room and
uh maybe it's maybe
he's not a shape shape-shifter but he's
got some excellent like hollywood makeup
you know and then like when he was
supposed to be in america he's not gonna
do it
and then you know then when they cut to
him over and [ __ ] being margaret that
shirt he's oh johnny
all right he just [ __ ] just changes
his voice he's like the mel blank of
like a the illuminati
that's what i think and i actually voted
for the [ __ ] i liked him
who's they supposed to vote for that
[ __ ] squinny pollock [ __ ] riding
around in the goddamn tank or was he a
greek
dude did you guys know copernicus the
guy who figured out that the [ __ ]
earth didn't go
you know was going around the sun that
the sun was the center of the universe
that guy was a polock all these polish
jokes
you know copernicus that doesn't sound
like a polish name to me
that sounds greek but i digress
so i go down there what do i get i get
the [ __ ] raisin bread
with the two percent milk there right
i got the milk from that cow that was
probably fed another cow so god knows
what kind of [ __ ]
uh poisons are in me right now but
there's only two percent of it as
opposed to four percent
you understand that right um two percent
of what i have no [ __ ] idea
i actually read something one time how
they do do the fat count
it's [ __ ] it's kind of like how they
do the gas mileage on the cars where
they drive the car at like two miles an
hour with like a [ __ ] hurricane wind
behind you
it gets 60 miles a gallon
um and then you get it you only get 20
and you're like what the [ __ ] they're
like well
you're stepping on the gas pedal too
much
well how do i make it go without doing
that sir why are you being hostile
because you're a [ __ ] that's why and
then you're out of then you're out of
the showroom
and that's it that's it
you ever go into a showroom and you see
the fingerprints on the glass and you
see
one set where they're really indented in
the window and then they kind of slide
to the right
that's the guy who used the c word he
said cut in the showroom and then was
dragged out
um yeah i don't know what i'm talking
about so yeah so i went with raisin bran
then i got a banana put it on top and
you know what i'm [ __ ] full
you know filled up the [ __ ] stomach
and i didn't go down there and and just
just you know just start your day
with [ __ ] 1200 calories to your ass
and now you're down to 800
and you know you're going to do that at
lunch and then you're done and then the
rest of the day
all it is is just [ __ ] overflow
spillage for your [ __ ] arteries and
your goddamn muffin top
all right why am i yelling at you guys
this week i don't know i'm [ __ ]
i'm in a great mood i'm going to go to
this [ __ ] game tonight it's going to
be tremendous
i'm going to have the whole road to
myself why because it's a sporting event
in atlanta telling you if they put
stripper poles down there they would
have [ __ ] sold it out and would it
cost me like nine grand a ticket
um so i actually i have an amazing week
i'm going to the basketball game tonight
and then i do a run of theaters i'm in
athens georgia on tuesday
i'm in alabama which georgia actually
looks down on which is [ __ ] hilarious
if you're not from this region
you know it's like you [ __ ] are all
the same to me you know
and i don't mean that in a bad way but i
don't mean it in a good way either
um alabama at the star dome on wednesday
and then thursday i'm over in
south carolina south carolina
and then uh no tuesday athens
wednesday stardom thursday south
carolina
and then friday i got two shows in
atlanta and then saturday i go to the
masters
you see that people you too can live the
dream
when you never get married and don't
have any kids you can live
selfishly like i do you know
and go to all these wonderful things and
brag about it on your own podcast and
then go to bed at night and cry yourself
to sleep
what the [ __ ] i keep hitting this
goddamn thing in this [ __ ] chair it's
driving me nuts
you know what you know it's almost like
the chair knows my ego is completely out
of control and just keeps let
let's bring him down a little bit a
little closer to the floor a little
closer to the regular people
all right just to show you what a [ __ ]
i am i'm going to read a couple of
a couple of ads here legal zoom
everybody
do you have a job that you hate you know
you want to get out of it
you want to start a business but you
don't want to sound like you're just
starting a business you want to sound
like you're actually making money
already
you know this is what you got to do you
got to go to legal zoom
oh wait that's e-voice what the hell am
i talking about
i can't even keep these damn things
straight legal zoom oh this is how you
set up the uh oh no wait this is it
right
is this it legalzoom's the one where you
uh
you turn yourself into a corporation
right off the bat right
bill why did you just read the copy you
[ __ ] [ __ ] all right here we go
legalzoom everybody look you've got a
plan for your future
we all know this you do financial
planning you get insurance
but to get real peace of mind you have
to make sure your family is legally
protected
um so where do you turn for affordable
legal protection you can trust why
legalzoom.com
for over 12 years they've been helping
americans get personalized wills
powers of attorney living trust real
estate documents and more
legalzoom also helps start and maintain
businesses with incorporation and llc
filings trademarks and copyrights their
time saving service was developed by a
team of experienced attorneys
and legalzoom takes care of you from
start to finish
legal zoom documents have been accepted
by courts and government agencies in all
50 states so it's totally legit
legalzoom is not a law firm but they can
connect you to an attorney and provide
self-help services at your specific
direction so if you need help
they're there to help you out they'll
walk you through the whole process for
even more savings enter burr
b-u-r-r in the referral box at checkout
um
if you're a parent or or an entrepreneur
don't wait any longer
call or visit legalzoom.com and protect
what's yours
all righty there's that and then of
course
what would a podcast be without a
stamps.com read everybody come on you
know the deal
are you still seriously are you still
going to the post office
you're still going down there unless you
unless you like routinely wear a brooch
there's no reason why you should still
be going to the you know down to the
the post office right the post office is
always crowded who's couldn't who
okay now it'll be even more crowded with
people mailing in their taxes
but you still need to get out envelopes
and packages for your businesses
so use stamps.com instead hey bill
what stamps.com all about well
stamps.com brings all the services for
the post office
right to your desk buy and print
official us postage for any letter or
package using your own computer and
printer
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
that automatically calculates the exact
postage you need
you'll never have to go to the post
office again
stamps.com they're your friends it's so
easy to use
that even a [ __ ] like me can use it no
wonderstamps.com printed
over one billion dollars in postage just
last year alone i use stamps.com to send
out all my dvds to all my fun little
shows
and i absolutely love not having to go
there right now use my last name burr
burr for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110
bonus offer includes the digital scale
and up to 55 dollars in free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the home page
and type in bur b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com
enter bur all right back to the podcast
uh dumb ways to die
so many dumb ways to die the [ __ ]
song's in my head i'm going to hook you
guys up with a youtube video
and i know it already has 40 something
million hits
and people be like way to be on the
cutting edge of youtube
i for all you dumb [ __ ] out there
40 million hits 40 million people is not
even one percent of the world population
okay so any sort of of recommendation
for a goddamn video is fine
all right so go [ __ ] yourselves hey what
do you guys think is worse uh
the the the uh atlanta braves fans
doing that tomahawk chop or red sox fans
singing sweet caroline
i'll let you think it over i have to be
honest with you just because it's
offending a [ __ ]
group of people that were victims of
genocide i got to go with tomahawk chop
but i have to say
um sweet caroline is a close second
i mean that's literally stopped me from
watching [ __ ] home games of the
boston red sox that in the whole steroid
error
i stopped watching in 2010 you know once
like [ __ ] half the red sox tested
positive
was it really half bill or was it two or
three key guys two or three key guys
you know and one guy who think escaped
town via chicago
and never [ __ ] got caught for
anything um
that's just you know just speculation
pure speculation people
but um yeah so i was kind of at that
point i was like all right they either
need to make steroids legal
or get it out of the game because i'm
sick of getting excited about [ __ ]
and then uh four years later you tell me
that it doesn't really count
you know i don't [ __ ] know um
this is how long it's been since i've
watched the red sox game i'm looking at
the usa today
sports page and it's got a picture of a
boston red sox who i don't even
recognize and it says middle brooks
shows clout with three home run day
evidently there's a guy in the red sox
called will
middlebrooks who was four for five with
three home runs and four rbis sunday
and he's batting 320 for the season i
have that guy
could [ __ ]
he could be sitting down next to me in a
[ __ ] restaurant i'd have no idea who
he was i'd be like who's that
really in shape tire salesman he's not a
tire salesman why that's that's [ __ ]
will middlebrooks
middle brooks it's not middle brook
middle brooks
the middle brooks the middle brooks
family everybody so evidently we got a
guy named will middlebrooks
i'll tell you right now if y'all you
know i gotta tell you if i'm the yankees
right now i gotta be worried about that
will middlebrooks
um i don't even know what i have no idea
what's going what is going on in
baseball right now
are they finally done building all new
stadiums
and singing dumbass [ __ ] songs just
make the roids
legal okay
just let everybody take them and then
it'll be alright
and then we'll all take them everybody
takes them
everybody's jacked everybody's got a
short [ __ ] temper
you know i guess that would suck but no
you don't do you really get that anymore
well bill who knows you it's not like
you [ __ ] read about it
um let's get let's talk about a sport
that maybe i know a little bit about
let's talk about hockey
i'm telling you [ __ ] [ __ ] right now
who roll your eyes at hockey first of
all if you don't want to be a fat [ __ ]
take up the game of hockey it's the it's
i'm telling you i've seen i say this
week in and
week out it is the greatest old man
sport there is
all these [ __ ] old white dudes go out
there and they're still playing [ __ ]
hoop what happens they come in monday
they blew out their [ __ ] achilles
you know constantly [ __ ] up your
knees your hips your feet because you're
running up the court
right and you got on your [ __ ] steve
jobs new balance
you know that the the official old white
guy sneakers which i just bought a new
pair of them
with the inserts that's when you know
you're old
um constantly getting [ __ ] hurt
right baseball nobody plays baseball
you play softball and that's just really
an excuse to get absolutely [ __ ]
hammered and eat hot dogs you actually
softball leagues you actually [ __ ]
gain weight playing the [ __ ] game
so that's no good now you're walking
around with this big [ __ ] gut
you know with your coaching shorts one
size fits all you look like you're in
your third trimester that's [ __ ] out
you sure as hell not gonna play football
in any sort of capacity
and that leaves hockey hockey's great
because you're running around but you're
gliding
you know i'm telling you
you [ __ ] work up an unbelievable
sweat it's great hand-eye coordination
and uh i'm completely 100 so i don't
even go to the [ __ ] gym anymore
i just go out and i get involved in a
pickup game i'm actually to the point
i'm at the upper level of sucking i can
actually stick in a little bit and keep
my head up
before somebody takes the puck away from
me
but i'm getting a good sweat and it's a
beautiful game
um you know what's funny they have all
these different drills and i've been
skating with this uh
comic on nate craig who i [ __ ] uh
brought out on tour when we went through
uh
wisconsin in [ __ ] michigan
and he was showing me a couple of drills
he went to one of these stick time
things and
it's just there's no hockey drill that
isn't absolutely
[ __ ] exhausting every [ __ ] one of
them
it's like you do three reps of it and
you you feel like you're gonna
absolutely you're gonna die
you know you ever see baseball players
before a [ __ ] game
just sort of limbering up you know just
tossing the ball flicking the wrist
that's the [ __ ] sport you wanna play
i think but then you gotta you gotta do
it 162 [ __ ] times
i would love to get a professional
baseball player on this podcast
and just talk to him about july and
august
and like how much even though you're
making millions of dollars how much you
want to kill yourself
how many [ __ ] times at that point
you've heard the song take me out to the
ball game 125 [ __ ] times
take me out to the ball game
you just sitting there like i'm gonna
[ __ ] kill myself
and you're standing out there in the
goddamn sun
right and now you gotta try to figure
out who this [ __ ] guy is on the mound
and what the hell he's putting on the
goddamn ball
like baseball it to me is literally it's
like going to math class every [ __ ]
day i i just i wouldn't have the
there's no [ __ ] way i could ever get
smart enough
to play that game at any sort of [ __ ]
level
well i just can't like when you played
football you just [ __ ] walk up and
you just play
right i don't get i guess you have to
figure out the guy across the line from
you
but not to the level of that these guys
have to
you know what i mean like maybe you
figure the guy out for part of the game
they don't come in and
you know all of a sudden bringing a
[ __ ] new cornerback out of nowhere
they do that with these hitters all of a
sudden you got a new [ __ ] picture
what the [ __ ] this guy doing
what's his deal what's his release point
can i pick it up as it's coming off his
fingers there's no
[ __ ] way there's no [ __ ] way
the only way i would ever make it in
professional baseball is if i
if i was a really good third base coach
if i really knew how to give the [ __ ]
signs
that's the only way i could ever make it
even if i had the god-given ability i
don't have the mental
stamina to give a [ __ ]
when another guy comes like i just
[ __ ] did this
i just figured out a guy now you're
bringing in another guy [ __ ] this game
[ __ ] this i'm gonna be an announcer
you know i'm gonna i stole this story
from uh this morning because they didn't
get to it on the uh the wonderful
program the uh the regular guys here in
atlanta
some [ __ ] [ __ ] spent over 200
grand on a star trek ray gun
all right 200 [ __ ] grand
over 200 grand from some rare ray gun
i guess used on the star trek episode
and this is what i want to know
how much crooked [ __ ] has the baby boom
generation done that they can afford to
throw their money around
like that you ever watch those barrett
jackson auctions
and like a mustang will come up this is
an actual shelby this is the real
deal we're gonna start the bidding at
180 000
who the [ __ ] has a hundred and eighty
grand to buy a mustang
you know they're sitting there [ __ ]
bidding on those [ __ ] ferraris come
up
that one from ferris bueller's day off
comes up or whatever and then they could
spend like 9 million bucks on it dude
right there
you should be [ __ ] thrown in a black
van
and [ __ ] take it down underneath the
pentagon and they figure out what the
[ __ ] you did where did you get your
money
huh they probably know you you know
something if you've got if you have
enough money
well you can blow 9 million bucks on a
goddamn ferrari
that you're not even gonna drive because
it's worth so much [ __ ] money
your wife doesn't give you [ __ ] at that
point you ha you know people at the
pentagon
right you walk into the federal reserve
and they shout out your name like your
[ __ ] norm on cheers
that's all i think of when i watch those
auctions i'm like
this is all filthy [ __ ] money nobody
has this kind of money
barrett-jackson you ever see a-rod there
a-rod doesn't even have that kind of
money
a-rod my favorite yankee of all
[ __ ] time
i don't know about any other red sox
fans i'm sort of a former red sox fan i
think eventually i'll get back into them
i kind of liked last year where they
sucked
and everybody you know just kind of burn
off all the pink hats you know
but now i guess they're good so
everybody's jumping back on the
bandwagon i got to figure out when's a
good time to
jump back in with those guys you know um
anyways you know i probably do it this
year at this point it makes me feel bad
as a fan that i don't know who [ __ ]
will
middle brooks
dude did you just get the new will
middlebrooks jersey i have no [ __ ]
idea who he is this is terrible
um anyways what the [ __ ] was i just
talking about
it's talking about knowing people in the
pentagon oh my favorite yankee of all
time
alex rodriguez watching the yankees
trying to shame
a-rod into demanding a trade has been
one and and him
not taking the bait you know sitting him
in the ninth inning in the playoffs
and he just still is just like no you
know me whatever is good for the team
[Laughter]
hey new york yankees front office just
settle in you're gonna have to pay him
every [ __ ] dime i bet that they have
his contract out on
their [ __ ] giant walnut tables every
[ __ ] is walnut expensive i don't know
every goddamn day just pouring they
probably have a team of lawyers just
just
specifically designed to pour over that
guy's contract
to try and figure out how the [ __ ] they
can get out of this i swear to god
if a rod was abroad and [ __ ] the
yankees
what where where where were his husband
all right this story would have already
been on the first 48 because a-rod would
have got
whacked that's that's the type of
financial [ __ ] situation there you
know when the the guy just
is like there's no way out of this i
just have to kill her you know which is
always the dumbest [ __ ] move ever you
know what i mean
you're going to go to hell forever if
that shit's true
something's gonna happen something has
to happen i think
you know what i mean because some people
get away with murder so there has to be
some sort of [ __ ]
something right in another world
or did they just put that in your head
because if there really was no
ramifications
they didn't make that [ __ ] up that
people would just be walking around
killing people
can you imagine if you just had no
[ __ ] conscience you just did that
anybody who's just annoying you you just
[ __ ] killed them
and you were so good at it you never got
caught
you know
with that could you still enjoy life
i guess if you don't have a conscience
i'm trying to think how many people i
would actually like seriously would have
killed i don't think i ever would have
killed anybody
that's an interesting question
nah i don't think i could
oh there's been a few i'd wanted to all
right let's get to the questions this
week before i [ __ ]
start incriminating myself um
when it rains it pours hey you
red-headed bastard
so i know this is going to be a horrible
email but i listen to your podcast
every [ __ ] monday tuesday wednesday
or whenever you get it up here will you
guys stop
saying [ __ ] wednesday it's not even
tuesday it's late monday you [ __ ]
whining [ __ ]
for the last [ __ ] time i tape it
monday morning my time it's not about
you
it's about me so go [ __ ] yourselves
[ __ ] bitching about a free goddamn
podcast you guys
the internet is a bunch of whiny [ __ ]
whiny unoriginal [ __ ] by the way all
right
you people out there you gotta set up
you gotta [ __ ] step up your twitter
game
stop using stock [ __ ] lines
i want the last three minutes and 28
seconds of my life back it's just like
isn't that the most unoriginal [ __ ]
thing ever
i just threw up in my mouth a little bit
like you've read that a million [ __ ]
times
on on [ __ ] twitter and you're gonna
write it again
like like you're gonna get a laugh
you know has anybody ever come up to you
told you a [ __ ] street joke
and then right after that told it to you
again no
because it's only funny once but you
[ __ ] twitter hacks
the same [ __ ] that feeling when
wait what that's like the [ __ ] hacky
tag
same [ __ ] people will then [ __ ] that
there's no [ __ ] original tv [ __ ] out
there and then they're just these
unoriginal [ __ ]
and you know what's funny they're all
they're just repeating [ __ ] that they've
heard and then they're all laughing
their [ __ ] asses off
at their own [ __ ] it's [ __ ] annoying
well i forgot to bring up the hockey
thing i was gonna say uh
you know what's killing me right now is
i think because of the injuries that the
the penguins have and the fact that the
[ __ ] bruins can't score more than two
goals a [ __ ] game
i actually think that the canadians are
the team to beat right now in the east
and it [ __ ] kills me
that those [ __ ] are looking like they
actually have a shot at winning a cup
this year
because there's nothing i enjoy more
than the fact that the montreal
canadiens are just not a factor anymore
but they're never gonna be a factor
ever again you know the way that they
were i mean it's
a [ __ ] 30 team league now you know
i mean dominating a [ __ ] six-team
league
is it's r it's really the the of all
like you know they look back at the
yankee dynasty the celtics the [ __ ]
packers and steelers and then the
canadians the canadians is the most
that one has the most [ __ ] holes in
it you know what i mean you dominated a
six team [ __ ] you had to beat five
other [ __ ] teams
okay four of which were in the united
states of america
a country that could give a flying [ __ ]
about hockey
nobody wanted to be the next rocket
richard down here
they wanted to be the next mickey mantle
nobody gave a [ __ ]
so four out of the five teams all you
had to be pete was the maple leafs
and in fact up until 1967 as far as
stanley cups went
it uh the canadians and the maple leafs
were going blow for blow
they didn't win this is this is how much
hockey didn't mean [ __ ] in this country
i saw a story one time on um on the nhl
channel
the radio morning radio program where
they were talking about how the rangers
finally made it to the stanley cup
finals
and madison square garden so didn't give
a [ __ ] about hockey every year
they booked the circus in madison square
garden
during the time when the stanley cup
finals was
so the [ __ ] rangers make it and
they're like [ __ ] you we already have
the circus and they're like but wait a
minute
we're in the stanley cup finals and they
go yeah but we got elephants go [ __ ]
yourself
so the rangers had to play their home
games they put them in toronto because
they were playing detroit and they
figured
toronto was the closest you know i guess
i don't know
to [ __ ] detroit so maybe you'd get
some toronto fans that hated detroit
i don't know why they just didn't send
them to chicago who the [ __ ] knows but
that's that's that's how much hockey
meant
you know so that's what i'm saying i
look at that dynasty like it's [ __ ]
[ __ ]
um not [ __ ] i respect it but it's
kind of like
you know okay
five other [ __ ] teams wow did you go
on a run that's amazing you had a one in
five [ __ ] chance of winning it
how did you do it um so my name is bill
hey you're redheaded bastard
so i know but anyways um i've been
riding
on a high point for the first time this
month and i wanted to get your opinion
on this matter
i was on a low point when it came to the
ladies
and i couldn't bag a 300 pound baldi for
the life of me
uh baldi you talking about a woman here
same with
a fatty with a shaved [ __ ] what are you
talking about all of a sudden i've been
landing every hot broad i've been
interested in for the last
past six months and i just don't [ __ ]
get it well dude don't overthink it
it's like golf don't get in your head
just [ __ ] swing away
um how does it work that nothing about
me has really changed besides i bought a
new shirt
and maybe did a few more pull-ups than
normal but it just seems like when it's
raining it's pouring [ __ ]
do women smell it on you or what i'm not
exaggerating this man i've landed two of
the hottest girls i've ever met in my
entire life
this past two weeks i just wanted to ask
the age-old
question why in the [ __ ] does this all
happen at once
why can't life space this out so i can
ride the wave for a year or two and be
happy instead of having it all happen at
once
and life sucks eight out of 12 months of
the year um
because getting [ __ ] it's like
playing golf it's a [ __ ] mental game
all right and if you have a bad shot you
got to block the last one out
it's like a relief pitcher you let up a
home run [ __ ] it give me another ball
and just block you gotta block it out
but what happens is
is you know you start to feel like
you're in a slump
and then you get desperate and [ __ ]
women just they smell it on you
you're coming in there you know you're
trying too hard extra splash of cologne
you're you're [ __ ] you're right in
their grill
like louisville full court [ __ ] press
you're right up on that [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then that's it it's over
they get all nervous and they pick up
their ball and they go home
you know you can't give a [ __ ]
the only i've only golfed a few times
but like i don't keep score i refuse to
give a [ __ ] about that sport and
i have a great time and everybody else
is [ __ ] throwing their clubs and
getting all pissed off
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm having a great
time you know what i'm going for the
hole i'm going for the pin
you know i [ __ ] miss and i suck but
i'm having a good time
that's all you got to do you got to go
phil mickelson on these [ __ ]
all right don't [ __ ] try and two-putt
and get par
go for the birdie
[Laughter]
you know what if you miss it who gives a
[ __ ]
you got to stay in that zone and not
giving a [ __ ] sir and even then you're
still gonna
there's gonna be feast of famine that's
that's just how it is
if i knew the answer to that you know i
would have done much better
in my uh my pathetic trying to get some
career
um all right book of job
god is the glory of vegas
okay hey hey bill listening to the
podcast and religious
the religious douche giving his douchey
impression of the story of job pissed me
off
first of all the phrase he got
jobbed is actually derived from the
story of job
oh we just pronounce it right dude is it
is it job
or job i don't [ __ ] know
um here's why first of all christians
condemn gambling and yet hold bingo
parties in the church parlors every week
but the book of job actually reveals
that god god is all for gambling
because not only did god make the very
first wager
god was also the first pit boss and
heaven was the first casino
i like where this guy's going um the
bible story
is that job was so devastated to devoted
to god sorry that there was no way
he would ever curse god's name the devil
went to heaven and said to god
uh no [ __ ] he won't curse you he's rich
as [ __ ] he's got a hot wife
seven no non-gay sons
and three great-looking daughters who
who don't date
give me five minutes with that piece of
[ __ ] and i'll get him to curse you
upside down
until next tuesday and god said
uh yeah you want to make a [ __ ] wager
see god knew job god made job
god knew 100 for certain that he would
win this
this bet uh bingo god is now the first
casino boss because god has an inside
knowledge of the game
god even gave the devil the odds so they
shook on it and the devil goes out
[ __ ] over jobs something fierce raped
and killed his kids
holy sh kids raped and killed his kids
really
burned all his house and crops killed
all his livestock but the worst
the devil essentially gave job herpes
but not just to job's wife
uh what the [ __ ] herpes but not to job's
wife
try explaining that to your wife without
at least cursing god a little under your
breath but job never caved so god won
the bet
of course god won it's god god did give
job all his stuff back
but now but how stupid was the devil
that he bet against god
the same as all of us when we go to
vegas and come out saying i got job
oh jesus christ that was so [ __ ]
clever it made my [ __ ] head
burst i think you're absolutely right
but i i just i got halfway through that
story and it's like there's no way that
someone wouldn't wouldn't freak the [ __ ]
out
raped his [ __ ] kids why is the bible
just so [ __ ] violent like that
and you just have to sit there and like
you know why because that they want you
to be just completely 100
percent devoted to the [ __ ] that
they're giving you that the invisible
guy is saying their version of what the
invisible guy is saying
to the point that someone can come and
rape your kids burn down your houses and
your crops
kill all your livestock and at no point
you're not supposed to be like god damn
it
at any point you're not supposed to
[ __ ] say that
and if you don't god's gonna give you
everything back he isn't
horrible [ __ ] happen to people's
families like that
any and and god doesn't come back and
make it [ __ ] better but [ __ ]
idiots
will go to church and they'll hear that
[ __ ] story and they will believe it
sorry sir you made a great that almost
seemed like a very caroline s kind of
bit there
um sorry it's just my [ __ ]
opinion on uh organized religion i get a
little flustered i get a little hot
under the collar
um law school or bust hey bill love the
podcast nobody live
so my question has to do with the law
school um
oh with law school my brain is not
[ __ ] working today
i'm gonna be done my first year of law
school in three weeks
and i hated it i have never found
anything i like to do
in my life other than you the usual
underachievable things
like my love for hockey and football i
hate every job i have ever had and i
thought law school might be the answer
but it's not
well but it has not been i cannot stand
law school and i cannot stand the
thought of the career in law
these professors always talk about all
the rules all the restrictions all the
dealing face to face with people's
problems it sounds exhausting it sounds
not fun at all
and i have zero enjoyment from it
i already know the answer to your
problems here sir or at least i feel i
do
um he said my question is this my
friends and family all say this is just
part of life
nobody loves their job nobody likes
school etc
but i see these people who love their
jobs i see people in my class that love
their law school stuff
i don't know whether i should stick it
out in school and just pray it grows on
me the debts from law school are insane
um i hope it grows on me like everyone
says it might
or should i take the plunge and change
direction complete completely look for
something else that pulls my excitement
i do not know what to do and it weighs
on me daily thanks and go [ __ ] yourself
uh dude you're ignoring
your inner voice which is saying i don't
like this [ __ ]
okay and what you're gonna but it's a
safe way to go
you get a law degree you become a
partner right and all of a sudden you're
making money
and you [ __ ] hate your life and you
know what you're going to bring that
home
to your wife and your kids and you're
going to be an [ __ ] husband and
father
and because you hate your [ __ ] job
all right or you could possibly do that
who knows you could come home and just
[ __ ] leave it at the front door
look dude all right you said you have a
love for hockey and football do you know
how many [ __ ] jobs there are why
don't you go into that
you know if you're going to stick with
law school i become a sports agent
so you at least around it but if i was
into hockey or football
i don't know i would i would try to get
into broadcasting get into journalism
uh maybe become a sports trainer or
something there's all kinds of jobs at
the
high school work your way up to college
and all that type of [ __ ]
you know i would go that route if you
like sports and you're into that
you know that there's this philosophy by
a lot of people who don't go after their
[ __ ] dreams
that if you if you that those aren't
real jobs like getting
in in any sort of entertainment or
having any sort of an exciting
[ __ ] job like it'd be i don't know be
one of those those
white water rafting guides those [ __ ]
people
you know who get all kinds of [ __ ]
[ __ ] because you got these people
who this is their one week vacation from
the job they hate and they see this
person who's totally free
loving life you know women oh my god
that looks oh that looks fun i need it
inside me
right because you know they're getting
banged up against some rock right next
to the coors [ __ ] factory
um
that's what i would do sir you sound
absolutely [ __ ] miserable it seems
like you love hockey and football so i
would try and find a job
in hockey and football and i know that
sounds [ __ ] insane
but you know so is telling jokes for a
living
i wasn't the funniest guy in high school
i was funny but i wasn't the funniest
i just went to a [ __ ] open mic and i
turned everything that i used to get in
trouble for into now i make money
and now i'm here in atlanta two feet
from a [ __ ] airport breathing in jet
fuel gonna go to the ncaa championship
game because i tell jokes for [ __ ]
living
you too sir can live your dream if a
dumb [ __ ] like me could do it you can do
it too
it sounds like you absolutely [ __ ]
hate
being and being in law school all right
it's going to be terrible dude then you
become a lawyer and then because you
hate it you're going to be looking for a
big score
you know and you're going to do some you
know some some sort of corruptable
[ __ ] thing to get your [ __ ] money
so you can parachute your way out of
there
you can be sitting in your stupid office
with your cufflinks and your little tie
tack
just counting down the days you know
to when you you [ __ ] have a vacation
dude you're going to be a trial lawyer
and somebody's freedom is going to be on
the line and you're not going to have
any [ __ ] passion for it you're going
to be sitting across them and going oh
my god if i listen to
listen to one more person tell me that
drugs were planted on them
you mean you i'm telling you don't
[ __ ] do it
all right you can have a fun job and
make money it's one of the biggest
[ __ ] lies
that's told by the generation and and
you know if your parents are [ __ ]
miserable and they hate their job they
don't know
they don't know so they're telling you
what they know that you know what life's
tough and you go and you
sit there and you hit the books you have
this [ __ ] miserable [ __ ] existence
you don't have to do it
look at all these [ __ ] people writing
blogs
there's [ __ ] people out there who
like they're into food i'm a foodie and
they go around oh my god the apple had a
little too much cinnamon on it they take
pictures of it
next you know they got advertising and
they're making money sitting there in
the [ __ ] pajamas eating fruit loops
reviewing it
making money you can't make money in
[ __ ] hockey and football
i uh you're out of your [ __ ] mind sir
i felt the weight of your [ __ ] life
reading that thing all right so please
for the love of god
for all the innocent men that you're
gonna defend half-heartedly
in the future please tap out of that
[ __ ] industry
and go someplace that you give a [ __ ]
all right and that's it sir
and you know what that's one to grow on
uh meet and greets
hey bill i'm curious uh what you think
about the meet and greet taking pictures
etc with people who attend your shows is
it completely awkward
i [ __ ] hate that word stop using that
word
such a [ __ ] overly used goddamn word
the whole [ __ ] generation
the sun is shining awkward laughing my
ass off shaking my head tweet
um do you enjoy it is it nice to hear
people tell you how funny you are or
does it just become ridiculous
i see pictures that fans take with
artists and always wonder if the artists
are thinking kill me now
or if they appreciate someone wanting to
take a picture with them in that setting
have a great day and go [ __ ] yourself um
the meet and greet is like doing a whole
other show if you're tired it's a
[ __ ] pain in the ass
um but you know if you go out there
you you you know you put a [ __ ] smile
on your face you take pictures with
people
um it's really what it is what makes it
exhausting is
is 15 of the people 85 percent of
[ __ ] cool
it's the 15 that are [ __ ] hammered
and uh they're slapping you on the back
and therefore they've got they're
[ __ ] sweaty
there's a bunch of like you know i
understand why howie mandel does the
fist bump
[Laughter]
but um generally speaking you know i i
like going out there
i like going out there and having people
say hey you know i had a bad day and i
listened to the podcast you know i've
had people come up to me
and say you know their mom has cancer
and and like she watched all three of
your specials and and
you know they put a smile on her face i
mean that that's like
that's worth going out there and dealing
with
you know when you know one of my pet
peeves is when
somebody's much taller than me as a guy
and they put their arm around me
and their sweaty [ __ ] warm armpit is
resting on one of my shoulders i [ __ ]
hate that
all right but you know it makes it worth
it when you hear uh stories like that or
you got you know people who are going
off to war or came back or whatever and
they say they listen to your jokes so
that's there's always
there's always a couple of cool
conversations that uh
that makes it worth it um what makes it
annoying is when people don't have their
cell phones ready
or they hand them to somebody
they don't even know and then they don't
know how to use the phone and then they
get upset because this complete stranger
doesn't know how to use this phone
that's not even theirs
and uh at that point you already have
your arms around these complete
strangers and then
that gets a little weird uh but you know
it's a part of it
you know you don't like [ __ ] doing
that then uh you know don't
don't uh don't jump on stage
you know that's how i look at it i mean
sometimes i don't go out there if i'm
[ __ ] exhausted and i feel like i'm
getting sick i won't go out there
because
you know i'm gonna go out there shaking
all these [ __ ] hands and get
everybody's germs all over me then i'm
gonna get sick and then my next show
is gonna suck because i'm gonna be sick
and it you know i have that's
my first obligation is you paid a ticket
to see me give you a great [ __ ] show
and if i don't do that
um you know what's the point
all right so there you go all right
single man advice
oh also but i got to be honest with you
too um when i first used to go out there
you mean it's a skill to know how to
actually talk and interact it's like a
whole new skill you have to learn so
um i wasn't good at it at first
um i just feel like hey how are you
did you like the show you know i was
really bad at it and um through watching
certain people who were just naturally
good at it like i always thought dane
was really good at it
um kevin hart i thought was really just
naturally good at it and i would just
kind of watch how they interacted with
people
and uh tried to use that as a
i don't know it was a guideline on how
to [ __ ] do it you know
so anyways but i have to admit like
it people never used to do that like the
the interaction that you guys have now
with with people that you see at shows
is [ __ ] insane
you know i went to i went to a no doubt
concert and she was like taking pictures
like grabbing people's cell phones and
taking like [ __ ] selfies i guess is
what they call them
with people in the [ __ ] crowd and i
actually found that annoying
it's like i came here to see you guys
all right
you know i know now you have to kiss the
crowd's ass to like some [ __ ]
unbelievable level but i just think it
like knocks down it's like you're a
[ __ ] rock star be a rock star
you should be that accessible you know
i don't [ __ ] know whatever here we go
single man advice
hi bill um okay maybe
just bill maybe a little more than that
no just bill
i'm keeping the intro simple i'm single
and need advice
i don't know what soup to choose i'm
really fond of clam
chowder are these euphemisms for
different kinds of
women really fond of clam chowder
alright so you're like a pasty redhead
but know that chicken noodle soup would
be better
paint the picture of the classic
bachelor role what
you guys why do you guys leave out like
four words in a row and just make me
sound even dumber than i am
which soup would look better spilled on
the plain white t-shirt
also i just cleaned my apartment after
letting the dust build for a while is
this a problem thanks for the advice
thanks for any advice it worked
single man advice do i really have to
answer this [ __ ] thing
what you look back dude clam chowder is
like crustacean
jizz club chowder is [ __ ] disgusting
it's [ __ ] gross it's like lobster
puke
ah it's just warm with that chunks of
[ __ ] now all the women are turning this
off but it's [ __ ] clam chowder
is it's octopus jizz
okay an octopus that's taking propecia
and is having a reaction to it
and that's what those chunks are um
chicken noodle soup come on man that's
hardy that's good stuff
that broth is barely going to show up
dude if you [ __ ] you know if yeah you
get clam chowder on your t-shirt people
are going to think you took a [ __ ]
hot one to the face dribbled off your
goddamn chin
wow disgusting lobster puke
octopus jizz and then a [ __ ] mail on
mail facial
to end the [ __ ] podcast how do you
like that huh right there
[ __ ] two point minus two points for
the dismount
um i think that that is the way are we
going to end with that
let's hype some of my shows here
everybody um oh by the way by the way i
almost forgot
to bring up the hard copy version of you
people are all the same for all the old
school
media consumption consumers whatever the
[ __ ] you say out there
if you're old school like me and if you
really like something you just don't
want to download it
i don't like doing that because i i if i
can't [ __ ] hold on to it
you know it's in the air man i don't
[ __ ] like that stuff where
you know it's on my itunes and it's it's
and it's on my [ __ ] uh my phone or my
ipod or whatever
i don't like that [ __ ] because those
things all die
and back in the day when your stereo
died you didn't lose your whole record
collection too so i am a big fan if you
like to have it's like having the gold
behind your money
all right if you'd like a hard copy
version either come out and see me live
or buy one off of the website
it's right underneath where uh you can
either download it for five bucks for
the kids that's the snowboarders
and if you still ski if you're old
school and you want the hard copy
it's available billboard.com right on
the merch page
and uh slowly but surely i am working on
some podcast t-shirts
um and that is it that's the podcast for
this week
let's uh let's quickly go to
billboard.com here who do you guys like
in the game tonight
who do you like i have family from the
midwest so i'm kind of
pulling from michigan but you know
louisville has got the whole broken leg
story
so i don't know who to vote for here who
to root for
but um i have to tell you that that
michigan seems to win on talent
you know like why how the [ __ ] they beat
syracuse was beyond me
because syracuse had this insane [ __ ]
zone defense and they were all the way
out by the three-point line so
immediately i'm thinking well just
[ __ ] fast break
don't let him get set up don't let the
ball touch the [ __ ] court do some
magic johnson showtime laker [ __ ]
get it up there and get some easy
[ __ ] layups and make them adjust to
your [ __ ] game
and they didn't they would just dribble
it up the court and let these [ __ ]
guys get
set up they couldn't beat the double
team like i feel like michigan is
getting
like because they're so young they're
just kids
i really feel that they're just kind of
getting away on raw talent
and now they're going up against rick
pitino
who's just a monster coach um i think
louisville's gonna take it
that's what i think but my heart i'll be
rooting for michigan
hail to the victors valiant
[Music]
do you know i also like ohio state
that's because i come from massachusetts
we don't really have any pro [ __ ] other
than doug flutie
[ __ ] stupid chair went down again
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] all right so this is the
deal i'm gonna be at the georgia theater
in athens georgia april 9th
um i'll be at the comedy club at the
star dome hoover alabama
april 10th i'll be in charleston music
hall
april 11th i'll be at the tabernacle for
not one but two shows friday night in
atlanta georgia april 12th
and then i got two shows at the improv
in tampa on monday i think those are
already sold out
um april 16th i have two shows at
florida state university
and april 17th i'm at the jackie gleason
fillmore theater in miami florida
later on this month i'll be in dallas
austin texas kansas city
i got a gig in las vegas anybody wants
to escape
an unhappy marriage and see me at the
mirage i'll be there on may 17th and
18th
um all my dates are up on billboard.com
thank you to everybody who's been
listening to the podcast
our numbers have been growing thanks to
uh the joe rogan
experience podcast for always giving
shout outs and links to my podcast
and if you listen to the jaymore sports
show i'm going to be calling that in
today
at 11 30 uh
am pacific standard time
that is it that's the podcast for this
week go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you
next week
[Music]
you